bonsoir alors je vais vous raconter une
histoire
cette histoire elle commence il ya
quatre ans à londres il ya quatre ans à
londres on est en 2010 on est au plein
coeur de la crise financière
moi je suis en deuxième année d'école de
commerce et on est au plein coeur de la
pire crise financière de tous les temps
tout casser les médias et les
spécialistes qui dit ça et pourtant tout
semble continuer comme avant
rien ne semble changer c'est à dire que
les enseignements restent les mêmes on
nous dit le but d'une entreprise est de
maximiser la valeur des actionnaires à
court terme et puis les jeunes
le rêve des jeunes c'est toujours de
rentrer dans les mêmes entreprises
celles qui sont la cause de cette crise
financière du coup moi je me dis mon
gars y'a un truc qui va pas qu'il tourne
pas rond et je me dis que j'ai pas envie
de contribuer à ça j'ai pas envie
d'aider un système qui dysfonctionnent à
être de plus en plus performant je pas
envie d'aider un système qui crée de la
pauvreté et de la précarité à mesure
qu'ils créent des richesses à être de
plus en plus performants je peux fait
toutes ses études pour contribuer à ça
donc du coup j'ai pris le problème
différemment et je me suis dit ok alors
qu'elle pourrait être le job de mes
rêves et je me suis dit
parmi tous les critères qu'on peut
imaginer j'adorerais que ce job il ya du
sens ça veut dire que le matin je me
lève et je sache à quoi je contribue je
sache pour quelle cause je me bats le
deuxième critère c'est être efficace
cette performance antirejets un impact
sentir que je fais bouger les choses que
ça va dans le bon sens et le troisième
c'est être passionné par ce que je fais
est tellement passionné que chaque matin
j'aille jouer où j'allais m'amuser et et
que j'aille pas travailler et peut-être
que ce raisonnement ses aspirations elle
vous parle en tout cas moi si je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est pour vous encourager à
continuer ses inspirations si vous les
avez et surtout vous dire que c'est
possible
créé le job de ses rêves c'est possible
alors j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer le
professeur yunus prix nobel de la paix
inventeur de du microcrédit du concept
de social business est en fait lire ses
livres puis rencontré sam sam un peu
ouvert l'esprit j'ai découvert
l'entrepreneuriat social au sens charge
en fait le fait de dire qu'une
entreprise peut avoir pour but
d'optimiser les profits et 2
maximisez et peut avoir pour finalité de
résoudre des problèmes sociaux et ou
environnementaux non couverts ni par
l'état ni par les entreprises ni par les
associations et je trouvais ça génial
parce que ça permettait de réunir
l'efficacité des entreprises avec
l'utilité sociale des associations dont
le concept il est top et avec un copain
jonas on s'est dit ça c'est cool mais à
quoi ça ressemble sur le terrain donc on
est parti on a pris notre sac à dos et
on est allé voyager autour du monde
on a eu la chance de le vivre avec des
gens exceptionnels
on a les trois mois j'ai vécu trois mois
dans la cave de ce monsieur là antonio
mais l'auto aux philippines en tonneau
mais l'auto il a créé gawad kalinka
comme il avait à peu près 40 ans il
était cadre dans une grande entreprise
et il s'est dit il pouvait plus
supporter en fait de devoir qui avait 30
millions de philippins qui étaient en
situation d'extrême pauvreté 30 millions
sur 5 millions quand même alors que lui
tu vivais très bien il s'est dit qu'est
ce que je peux faire moi aussi donc il
s'est mis à faire des immersions dans
des bidonvilles pour comprendre les
causes de l'extrême pauvreté
et puis là il a initié des
expérimentations il a aidé 50 familles à
sortir du bidonville et à construire en
dur leur maison et à le peindre en des
couleurs vives pour les aider à
retrouver leur dignité à retrouver leur
fierté et il a construit comme ça un
village puis deux puis trois puis 10 et
en dix ans il en a construit 2000 pour
un million de personnes
ensuite en inde j'ai rencontré les
fondateurs dharavi nike à l'hôpital
ophtalmologique le plus performant du
monde
il ya énormément d'indiens qui sont
atteints de la maladie d'une maladie
dans la cataracte
c'est dans l'oeil et si on la traite pas
on devient progressivement aveugle
évidemment cette opération elle coûte
cher coûte 200 dollars
mais cet hôpital a trouvé une innovation
technologique pour faire passer ce coup
là de 200 $ à 5 dollars et surtout ils
ont imaginé un système pour que les plus
démunis n'ait pas à payer ses les plus
aisés qui payent pour les autres ce qui
fait que il ya deux tiers des patients
qui bénéficient des soins gratuitement
et les autres payent le coût
complémentaire
ce modèle économique hybride a permis de
redonner la vue à 32 millions de
personnes en 36 ans et l'hôpital a
jamais réalisé de pertes en plus près de
chez nous dans le ch'nord
andré dupon qu'on voit à l'écran avec
vitamine t aide des personnes à se
réinsérer
donc c'est vitamine t c'est une
entreprise sociale d'insertion par
l'activité économique
concrètement ça aide des personnes qui
ont été cassés par la vie alors trouvé
le chemin du travail progressivement et
retrouver un emploi durable vitamine t
est spécialisée dans le recyclage de de
wes de produits électroménagers et donc
c'est un triple impact c'est un impact
économique social et environnemental
en 35 ans ça a permis quand même la
réinsertion de trente mille personnes
dans la société
tous ces exemples à sa montre une chose
pour moi c'est que l'impossible est
temporaire à chaque fois il ya des gens
qui se sont dit c'est pas possible on
peut pas continuer comme ça je vais
prendre une initiative
tout le monde se moquait d'eux et en
fait ça a marché ça montre que
l'impossible est temporaire alors ce que
j'ai découvert c'est que c'est ces gens
là que j'appelle entrepreneurs du
changement ces gens qui ont une idée
puisqu'il à mettre en oeuvre ce que j'ai
découvert ce n'était pas des gens
extraordinaires
c'était des gens ordinaires avec une
détermination extraordinaires et j'ai
découvert qu'il avait quatre très très
intéressant et surtout plus important
c'est que c'est très s'apprennent se
dire que chacun de nous est capable
d'apprendre c'est très pour devenir
entrepreneur du changement ces quatre
caractéristiques c'est un la cup a
imaginé un monde plus durable a
transformé les problèmes en opportunité
la deuxième c'est la détermination à
faire changer les lignes à faire beau à
faire bouger les lignes à faire changer
les choses c'est la capacité à se dire
je refuse la fatalité et à mon échelle
j'essaie d'agir la troisième c'est le
potentiel de leadership c'est la
capacité à transformer ses idées en
actions en emmenant d'autres pour les
réaliser et enfin la capacité à
communiquer son enthousiasme pour créer
un mouvement à grande
la grande échelle un mouvement de grande
ampleur est donc encore une fois c'est
très ça prenne on ne n'est pas
entrepreneur du changement on le devient
alors vous allez me dire ouais c'est
bien beau mais ils sont vieux ces gens
là ils ont beaucoup d'expérience et sait
alors on fait quoi quand on est jeune et
ben c'est une mauvaise excuse désolé
j'ai vu partout dans le monde plein de
jeunes qui se lancent est plein de
jeunes qui se lancent est de plus
en plus parce qu'il n'a jamais été aussi
simple de créer une entreprise ou une
association pour donner un premier
exemple makes sense est une communauté
de 18 mille bénévoles dans qui en quatre
ans organisé 750 résolution de défis
pour des entrepreneurs sociaux dans 100
villes du monde grâce au pouvoir des
nouvelles technologies un deuxième
exemple fabien courte et c'est un
français qui a quitté ses études à un
haut niveau de sa césure d'école de
commerce pour partir aux philippines il
s'est rendu compte qu'au finish il n'y
avait que des jouets et des des jouets
des peluches des peluches importés de
chine avec plein de produits chimiques
il n'y avait aucune production locale
aux philippines et donc il s'est dit je
vais lancer la première entreprise
sociale là dedans pour employer des gens
à la base de la pyramide pour créer de
l'emploi il est parti avec 350 euros
deux ans après il a vendu 35 mille
peluche il à créer 25 emplois
les personnes croyant lui quand il est
parti alors vous allez me dire ouais
mais ça c'est marginal c'est tout petit
et c'est ça concerne pas les grandes
entreprises
ça change pas de système alors pas
encore mais c'est en train les grands
groupes sont en train il me semble c'est
ce que j'ai découvert aussi d'évoluer
c'est à dire qu'il s'inspire de cette
démarche des entrepreneurs du changement
pour se réinventer en interne
je donnais 13 et trois exemples très
rapide schneider electric est en train
de développer des solutions solaires à
très bas coût pour permettre
l'électrification dans les zones rurales
pour les plus démunis
partout dans le monde danone est en
train de soutenir des petits producteurs
à vivre de leur production leur élevage
locale là c'est un exemple au sénégal
et puis ils développent des yaourts
enrichis en vitamines et en nutriments
au sénégal ou encore au bangladesh
et puis renault plus proche de chez nous
être des gens à avoir accès à la
mobilité durable à aider des gens qui
sont dans la grande précarité avoir
accès à un véhicule ou à la réparation
de leurs véhicules à moindre coût pour
permettre à chacun d'avoir accès à la
mobilité à retrouver un travail
vous allez me dire c'est de la
communication on connaît etc
oui mais dans ce cas là effectivement
non c'est pas de la communication
puisque ce sont des initiatives qui sont
portées au plus haut niveau de
l'entreprise sont portées par la
direction générale qui concerne
l'innovation à la stratégie et qui sont
un moteur de réinvention en interne ces
initiatives qui sont portées par des
entrepreneurs sociaux qui ont les mêmes
caractéristiques
dont on parlait juste avant alors j'ai
vu tout ça et j'ai trouvé ça fascinant
j'avais envie de participer à ce
mouvement mais je savais pas trop
comment et puis un jour je me suis
laissé embarquer dans une aventure
extraordinaire un voyage au coeur de mon
voyage en inde je suis parti pendant
quinze jours avec 450 jeunes à la
rencontre d'entrepreneurs qui avait
transformé l'inde
donc je suis parti rencontrer des gens
qui avaient changé la vie de 1 à 40
millions de personnes ça a duré 15 jours
et cette expérience elle m'a
complètement bouleversée et j'ai eu
envie de me lancer à mon tour pour en
fait m'inspirer de cette initiative en
inde
essayez de la répliquer et de l'adapter
en france ça s'appelle ticket de
forchheim un ticket pour le changement
changé sa vie pour changer celle des
autres c'est aider des jeunes à révéler
leur potentiel des jeunes et des moins
jeunes à rêver leur potentiel pour qu'il
puisse dévoiler leurs talents et puis
agir pour la société agir pour changer
la société par l'entrepreneuriat alors
très concrètement ça c'est beau comme
concept mais très concrètement pour
cette première année on a pris 50 jeunes
issus de tous milieux sociaux de bach -
5 à bac +5 et puis on les a emmenés
faire un tour de france pendant 12 jours
dans six villes de france de paris à
marseille à côté de valence à lyon à
strasbourg a passé deux jours à lille on
est revenu à paris et puis on a inventé
une pédagogie hyper innovante avec trois
coachs en leadership et en
transformation une pédagogie en u pour
aider à transformer ces rêveurs c'est
des gens qui avaient pas d'idées pour
changer la société et qui voulait le
faire qu'avec notre détermination de le
faire on a inventé une pédagogie pour
les transformer de rêveurs acteurs cette
pédagogie n'est en trois phases la
première c'est une phase d'inspiration à
la rencontre de 40 pionniers l'exception
des gens qui concilie impact social et
efficacité économique à la rencontre de
la france qui va bien la france qui ose
on a fait des immersions terrain pour
voir l'impact de ces de ces solutions
la deuxième phase le creux du eu c'est
une phase d'inspiration pour aider les
jeunes à identifier leurs talents leurs
passions leurs moteurs leurs aspirations
pour mieux les aider à transformer leurs
rêves et leur indignation en actions
concrètes qui est la troisième phase la
phase de mise en action
où il ya eu plein d'ateliers pour les
aider à transformer leurs rêves vos
projets concrets aujourd'hui il ya
quinze projets qui sont sortis et on les
accompagne sur le long terme
le but c'est de générer une nouvelle
génération d'entrepreneurs du changement
dans notre pays ça c'est une première
édition et on en prépare d'autres pour
l'avenir alors ce rêve là que j'avais
eue il ya un an et demi il m'a
complètement dépassé je m'imaginais pas
du tout à vivre ce que j'ai vécu ça m'a
amené en moins d'un an a rencontré le
président de la république et trois
ministres a levé 600 mille euros
manquants c'est complètement incapable
et puis j'ai pu lui aussi fait blesser
la courbe du chômage en france parce que
parce que j'ai créé mon job au lieu d'en
chercher mais surtout ce que ça veut
dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression d'avoir mon destin entre
mes mains et je pense que ça c'est le
plus important
alors si ça ça résonne en vous je vous
encourage à continuer dans cette voie et
puis très humblement g 10 conseils pour
vous aider à passer à l'action
très humblement je le dis parce que
c'est ce que j'ai vu au tour du monde
et puisque j'ai vécu par mon expérience
la première chose c'est explorer sortez
des sentiers battus prenez des prenez
des moments de respiration prenait des
années de césure si vous pouvez aller
voir le monde découvrir tel qu'il est
vraiment et puis multiplié les
expériences différentes
voilà pour pour voir dans quelle
situation vous êtes le plus à l'aise et
ce qui vous passionne le plus la
deuxième chose c'est ne mettez pas vos
idéaux de côté
gardez vos idéaux c'est la chose la plus
importante que vous ayez demandez-vous
ce qui est le plus important pour vous
dans votre vie écrivait le prenez un
carnet écrivez vos vidéos écrivez vos
rêves dedans et puis revenez-y tous les
six mois
c'est la chose la plus importante parce
que c'est vos idéaux vont vous aider à
devenir la personne que vous aspirez de
venir changer votre posture devenir un
entrepreneur du changement dans votre
posture c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
que vous voyez un problème arrêtez
d'essayer de pointer le doigt vers
quelqu'un vous trouver un coupable
essayez de vous demander ce que vous à
votre échelle vous pouvez essayer de
faire
changez votre posture aussi quand quand
vous avez un choix dans votre vie prenez
le plus courageux
suivez notre intuition arrêté de suivre
les dogmes devenez entrepreneur de votre
propre vie fait des choix qui vous qui
vous conviennent qu'ils sont dont vous
avez une intuition qui vous conviennent
le quatrième conseil s'est essayé
d'identifier le problème qui vous
indigne le plus dans le monde
le problème qui vous touchent le plus le
la chose que vous avez dans les tripes
et qui fait que vous allez pouvoir vous
battre pendant plusieurs années après
parce que vous êtes passionné par ce
problème
ne tombez pas amoureux de la solution
tombé amoureux du problème rêver grand
n'hésitez pas à rêver grand moi on m'a
aidé et j'ai eu des mentors qui m'ont
aidé à rêver à arriver dix fois plus
grand que ce que je pensais pouvoir
faire mais c'est grâce à eux qu'on a
fait quelque chose
huit fois plus grand que ce que je
pensais pouvoir faire rêver grand ça
vous aidera à attirer les meilleurs
talents dans votre équipe
l'équipe du coup j'y viens constitué une
dream team constituer une équipe avec
des gens qui vous inspirent des gens que
vous admirez des gens avec qui vous
allez aimer travailler et des gens et
qui vous allez aimer passer des moments
parce que vous allez passer des moments
très forts
vous allez vivre des hauts et des bas
mais des moments très difficiles aussi
donc il faut que ce soit des c'est votre
nouvelle famille dans votre aventure
entrepreneuriale donc choisissez ces
personnes c'est le plus important pour
que ça réussisse concrétiser fait un
premier pas agissez ça sert à rien
d'avoir un grand rêve si vous ne faites
rien vous gâcher tous fait un premier
pas aujourd'hui mené une première action
prototype et essayer fait recueilli des
feedback sur votre sur votre prototype
ne fait un business plan pendant dix
mois
testez les choses tout de suite auprès
de auprès de vos utilisateurs travaillé
très dur ces 13 ans enfin c'est une
évidence mais travailler très dur être
entrepreneur c'est excessivement
difficile alors quand on veut être
entrepreneur avec un double un triple
impact un entrepreneur qui a un impact
économique social et environnemental
c'est évidemment deux à trois fois plus
difficile
ces deux fois trois fois plus complexe
se multiplier problème alors travailler
faut travailler encore plus dur
et puis surtout soyez excessivement
exigeant avec la qualité c'est pas parce
qu'on fait un projet d'intérêt général
condat être plus laxiste avec la qualité
au contraire je pense
soyez hyper déterminer quand on va vous
dire que c'est pas possible ça ne
marchera pas c'est évident on va vous le
faire c'est bon signe ça veut dire que
vous avez une idée qui dérange que vous
avez une idée innovante et puis que vous
êtes ambitieux donc continuez continuez
et dans les moments de doute parce que
il y en aura aussi il ya eu des moments
très durs où je savais pas si j'allais
continuer je me suis rappelé d'un
conseil que j'avais reçues aux
philippines d'un entrepreneur social
ce conseil il est très simple c'est
n'abandonne jamais n'abandonne jamais
n'abandonne jamais ne sont jamais
abandonné pour l'instant ça a marché et
enfin douich will they faites le dans la
joie parce que c'est quand même génial
d'avoir trouvé le job qui nous passionne
et je suis quand même hyper heureux
d'avoir un job qui qui va me me rendre
heureux pendant au moins les 40 ans qui
arrive plus tôt que m'ennuyer au travail
et ça faut le reconnaître et ne pas
hésiter à le dire pour inspirer d'autres
essayer de faire la même chose
voilà pour pour conclure je la
conclusion elle est très simple c'est
croyez en vos rêves
croyez en vos rêves faisandé beaucoup
trop grand le travail est hyper dur
rassembler des gens autour de vous parce
que aucun rêve n'est impossible
aucun rêve n'est impossible moi mon rêve
c'est que chacun des jeunes en france et
dans le monde puisse vivre cette
expérience de se poser les questions de
ce qu'il veut vraiment faire de sa vie
et qu'ils puissent rencontrer des
modèles inspirants pour trouver sa vraie
vocation
ça c'est mon rêve aujourd'hui on est en
train de développer cette initiative qui
s'appellent ticket de fortes chances
pour que chaque jeune puisse y avoir
accès on mise sur le numérique et le
digital on lance un mook devenir
entrepreneur du changement et l'enjeu
est effectivement c'est que chacun
puisse vivre cette expérience
alors croyez en vos rêves parce que si
vous y croyez ils se réaliseront au
bonne route à vous